serious new trouble for new york
governor andrew cuomo he's already
facing calls for impeachment
and he's under federal investigation
over his nursing home scandal
but now a former aide is accusing the
governor of sexual harassment
lindsay boylan dropping bombshell
accusations today
they include unwanted kissing and
touching she also claims the governor
told her quote
let's play strip poker end quote and
that
top female staffers for cuomo quote
normalized
that kind of behavior boyle in detailing
one of her allegations saying here i'm
quoting
we were in his new york city office on
third avenue as i got up to leave and
walk toward an open door
he stepped in front of me and kissed me
on the lips i was in shock
but i kept walking and quote cuomo's
office issuing a denial today
saying the allegations are quote simply
false
and the governor himself has denied the
accusations in the past
jesse let me uh begin with you the
governor's getting hit from every
direction here
first the nursing home scandal now this
the pot is boiling is the governor
cooked
no he's close let's play strip poker has
to be the cheesiest pickup line
even i have ever heard this is the kind
of line they use in corporate sexual
harassment training programs
that it's so dopey even the politically
incorrect colleague in the way back
raises his hand and said
yeah you're not allowed to say that juan
i think i speak for the men and women on
this show that line has never worked
once
maybe if you're already drunk already
playing cards
and a freshman in college maybe but not
a 63 year old guy on a government plane
andrew cuomo strikes me as the kind of
guy that if he did play strip poker
he'd probably think it was really funny
to start off wearing lots of extra
layers of clothes
and make all the other women just start
off in t-shirts and shorts
that's the kind of guy he is but in all
seriousness i don't know if it's true or
not you know
he's innocent until proven guilty to he
said she said but it's obviously
a very credible accusation that needs to
be looked into very seriously
but juan he's everything he accused
donald trump of
an incompetent creepy lying jerk
who is denied the science and points his
fingers at anybody
besides himself and seeks media
adulation
this is he's projecting for the last
year
so right now you have a guy and i know
you're going to say juan i'm going to
cut you off
that his approval ratings are so great
well it's because he's a democrat
the democrats control the media and they
conduct the opinion surveys
we have that already figured out but why
is his numbers so good in the first
place
what did he actually do juan all he did
was shut down the new york economy
while trump bailed him out with ppe
ventilators in a vaccine
he gave misinformation at these press
conferences
and flushed all the wealthy people to
the hamptons and then he had time
all the other 49 governors didn't but he
had the time to write a book
about how great he did and managed to
have the highest death toll
of all the states of the nation so juan
this is not coming from me
a rank partisan this is coming from
other democrats who want the guy
impeached investigated and won his power
stripped
all right so greg uh the new york
congresswoman elise stefanik said today
that the governor is a criminal sexual
predator i'm quoting there
and she said he should resign now by the
way she's considering running for
governor so is lee zelda another
republican congressman from new york
can the republicans beat governor cuomo
who's seeking
would be seeking a fourth term yeah i
heard that he's actually writing another
book called it's not going to be okay
so dana you're going to have some
competition there i think i win
i i'm going to have to argue i'm going
to have to disagree with everything
jesse said clearly the sexual harassment
charge
is donald trump's fault uh it's his
callous sexist behavior
that so frustrated governor cuomo that
he seeked consolation from a member of
the opposite sex
so therefore i think this has to go to a
third impeachment of donald trump
here's the the most amusing part of it
actually it's the funny
the thing is the strip poker thing is a
is a great laugh line
but the unwanted kissing i mean that's
that is creepy and wrong and
uh it's just it's just but i'm not
surprised
but what is it with cnn's infatuation
uh with weirdos i mean they never result
in a happy ending i mean first there was
the recent romances were obviously
avenetti they thought he was going to be
the next big presidential hope and then
of course
they cnn had the guy from lincoln
project on almost like every hour
uh loved him and now you've got this
contender you know playing uh
q-tip uh comedy uh on uh with his
brother i'm beginning to think cnn is a
poor
judge of moral character um lastly
what worries me about cuomo is that the
left
are thrilled to get rid of him it makes
me think they have something worse up
their sleeve and dare i
say that is it possible that something
monstrous called de blasio would end up
running for governor
i mean could there be something actually
worse
than cuomo i mean because you're seeing
all the knives come out now it's like
that
it's like the end of the movie freaks
when they capture cleopatra
and they turn her into a duck it's not
as funny as it sounds
but it's just like this
well you know actually you took my next
question for dana because then i was
going to say
the democrats look like they are loaded
for beer going after cuomo
uh but last time around cynthia nixon
who was in sex in the city she ran
against him this time around they're
looking at leticia james who's the
attorney
general who really broke this scandal
and you have that
assemblyman who said that uh you know
cuomo bullied him so
do you think there's anybody who could
beat cuomo in a democratic primary
well i don't think it i don't care
really about the the democratic primary
i think that the republicans could win
think back to other governors of new
york's past like george pataki for
example
uh who was governor of new york um at 9
and worked hand in glove with rudy
giuliani to help bring back new york
city
and made that made new york a much
stronger
state so a lot of mid-atlantic to new
england states
they might have quite democratic
populations but they often will have
republican governors and that's the case
also currently right now
for example in massachusetts and new
hampshire one thing i think that's
interesting about this is
there's this reporter up in albany where
did my notes go
i had this great point to make
uh i found it i i because i wrote it
down i wanted she said
that there are have always been
democrats that were willing to trash
andrew cuomo on background because like
the things you hear about him being a
bully
those are true but it has there has been
a remarkable change in the last three
weeks where now
democrats that only used to talk on
black background are willing to do it on
the record
and that's when you know that cuomo is
in probably a lot of trouble
you know new york passed this big new
sexual harassment law that's one of the
reasons if you work in new york you have
to go to the sexual harassment training
that's quite intense and uh you have to
go every single year no matter what
um and now you wonder if cuomo went to
that you think about
when he was on with his brother chris
cuomo one of the big jokes was about how
andrew cuomo was now single ready to
mingle
maybe not so funny today and jesse next
time you start a rant like that please
let me hold your hand
maybe nervous ask first
uh degan uh picking up on something that
jesse mentioned
uh you know we see that even after the
nursing home scandal the governor's
approval rating is like 57 percent
and when you ask people about him you
know it's like 41 percent of new yorkers
say he did nothing illegal but maybe
unethical how do you understand the fact
that he seems to be skating above
all the static skating above
the ice is cracked he's going down what
are you talking about
61 percent of new york voters agree that
cuomo mishandled the crisis in nursing
homes
this is one of the reasons that
democrats are finally speaking out
about his bullying and intimidation and
the
threats that have gone on literally for
years
because he had a hand in killing
more than 15 000 elderly people and has
blamed
everybody from fox news to the new york
post to donald trump
he stonewalled and covered it up
they're done with him and i just you
enough people in new york in politics in
the media
and in the communities these uh the
grieving
families of the elderly who were killed
at by cuomo
are finally standing up to this ghoul
and you do have people like
ron kim the assemblyman a democrat
speaking out about the threats and i
just want to know
just one quick thing about ron kim's
story cuomo called him at home when he
was bathing his three
daughters and said i will destroy you he
was yelling
so loudly on the phone that kim's wife
and kids
left were frightened by it
cuomo told him you haven't seen my wrath
i will go out tomorrow and start telling
the world
how bad an assembly member you are and
you will be
finished janice dean told
the bosses here at fox that um she had
been warned by somebody who knows the
cuomo family
to watch her back when she started
speaking out about andy cuomo and he
sicked his flunky
rich as a party on janice dean
she was the one who said that she's not
a credible source on anything and then
went after her sister-in-law told her to
get a life
and a clue so right now anybody who
allegedly has been threatened or
harassed by andy cuomo
is safe enough more secure enough and
protected enough
that they should air what he did to them
allegedly all right